but it's been like a very different
challenge learning Japanese as like a
grown adult I would say because I don't
know has the fact that she were very
much into Japanese culture and watching
anime helped you at all from your
perspective yeah definitely I think it's
made it easier but like easy with an
asterisk right yes like yeah easier to
understand some concepts culturally that
might explain some of the language right
which is great but at the end of the day
it doesn't help me like in a crazy
amount yeah I think it just helps me
understand why certain things are the
way they are in a language yeah you know
why is it like you know why you can't be
direct to someone white soy su my senel
yeah it's never you know and then I
guess cuz sometimes in your learning
language you're like why can't I just be
like direct yeah that's not a thing you
can't do that that's it that's true
breasts yeah I think learning Japanese
for me I didn't realize how much I kind
of just zoned out Japanese when I
watched anime before oh yeah you do you
filter out cuz you're like that's that's
nonsense to me I'm yeah yeah you you
just like absorbing the subtitles and
you kind of just mute out the Japanese
and I didn't realize that until I
started learning when I when I actually
picked out individual like how the
sentence works and how the language
actually works that I realize oh oh this
didn't help me a lot at all but I find
it really hard in my head to recommend
learning language to people because I'm
I feel like if you're not gonna like
actually do it
mm-hmm it's kind of a waste of time I
know it takes committee yeah that's what
I said to people though about Japanese
and it's one of those things where like
learning Japanese especially if you're
not if you're not going to do it
full-time it's like at least a five year
thing but you have to commit to and if
you quit two-and-a-half years in you
know but that's the price that like so
many people I get quirk in emails about
it all - god damn being like what's the
easiest way to learn Japanese there is
no easy way to learn Japanese no you
just have to sit down and just be like
am I about to commit five to ten years
of my life to learn this [ __ ] yes it's
like any like skill chart right where
it's like the first like real getting
over the first real difficult like that
yeah yeah it's the hardest and once you
get past that you've gone through a
challenge yeah over can it normally you
could keep going let's say with any
craft right like voice acting as well
like photography
anything right you sure yeah there's
always like gonna be that that first
point where you think you're starting to
understand it then you get to that point
we all like [ __ ] I know nothing about
yeah and it's that point where if you
keep going and actually like starting
you know really put in the work you'll
probably see some results but a lot
people quit at that point cuz like I'm
always really paranoid and this is true
in my life and whenever I'm like doing a
playthrough of a game right when I'm
doing something and it's just sub
optimized yes like sometimes I like
paralyze myself because I'm just like
what if I'm not doing this most optimal
ways this waste of time I'm so scared of
wasting my time so when I first start
learning Japanese I spent more time
trying to figure out the best way to
learn Japanese yeah but actually
Japanese yeah I guess you're the
opposite sorry in that sense like I do
video games I'm definitely like that
I'll maximize the [ __ ] out of video
games but everything else in my life I'm
like that's good I'm kind of the
opposite with video games I'm just like
yeah yeah games just made to be like fun
and timely yeah cuz I'll talk to Jerry
about videos were both playing and I'll
be like you know this is like 2% more
efficient to do this like this method
right and Jerry's like Braun don't give
a [ __ ] and I've already put CCI